[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings a married
couple is suing a fertility clinic and
its owner over an ivf mix-up that led
two women to give birth to the other
person's baby
daphna and alexander cardinale accuse
the clinic of breach of contract and
medical malpractice now they say the
clinic and its owner handed their embryo
to a third party lab without their
knowledge this lawsuit alleges that the
lab had a history of mishandling the
embryos maria virial spoke to the couple
who say the mistake has left them with
lasting damage
it wasn't so easy naturally for us for
the second one
after having their first child daphna
and alexander cardinale needed help
having a second
using in vitro fertilization they got
pregnant and welcomed a baby girl in
september 2019
but immediately alexander felt something
was wrong
when was the point where you said
something's not right i had a weird sort
of a gut
reaction when she was born it was
anything logical it was just
it was just like a
instinct like a god like something
didn't feel right the baby didn't
resemble either parent and appear to be
of a different race
after two months of growing doubts they
ordered a dna test what was it like
opening those results
the whole thing feels so yeah
terrifying just numb
the tests confirmed their worst fear the
infant was not their biological daughter
when i found out she wasn't mine
and so i had like poured mo i poured
more love into her
i was just so scared i was going to lose
her which i ultimately did
daphna was implanted with a stranger's
embryo who in turn received theirs that
woman who wishes to remain anonymous
gave birth a week later to the
cardinali's biological daughter the
babies were four months old when this
was all figured out and the process of
returning the children to their
biological parents began
the cardinalis had to break the news to
their older daughter olivia having to
tell her that her four-month-old baby
sister
wasn't really her sister and that
there was another baby that
it was just a whole how do you say that
to a five-year-old and we struggled with
that for so long
we finally told her and
you know i think it's really profoundly
changed her the cardinality family is
now suing their physician the california
center for reproductive health and a
third party embryology lab for alleged
misconduct including medical malpractice
and negligence
according to the complaint ccrh thought
that the embryos had gotten mixed up
when an embryology lab in vitro tech was
taking biopsies to send in for genetic
testing in january of 2020 the
cardinalis brought home their biological
daughter zoe for good a bittersweet
moment that also brought a sense of
guilt and loss over the baby they gave
away when we
brought zoe home and we didn't know her
so we had to learn her and learn and
then track all that stuff like i i
watched her have to switch slowly from
caring and tracking from one baby to
another almost like morning
a child even though she wasn't the
couple says they're now fighting for
accountability someone needs to take
responsibility for this mistake
the cardinals say they keep in touch
with the other family and visit them a
couple times a month including birthdays
and holidays we did reach out to the
physician the clinic and the lab named
in this lawsuit but have yet to hear
back from any of them nate
maria thank you so much that is an
unbelievable story gosh i feel so angry
and so sad at the same time listen baby
luca kirby favorite daughter kirby son
also known as my grandson's only seven
weeks old and i see how much you bond so
quickly plus imagine the baby you gave
birth to wasn't yours so all that all
the kicking wasn't your baby
and now you have to deal with that but
i'm glad that it hap if it has to happen
that it's four months the baby won't
remember it's early enough it's early
enough but the parents will never forget
and you're never going to get those
three months back no you're not with
your baby that father thinking to
himself something's not right but maybe
i'm just you know thinking things you
know it's it's a it's a hard time in
your life in general you're not sleeping
and then to get that answer imagine
opening that envelope right wow he puts
in perspective it's like mourning the
loss of one and then learning an
entirely new baby that sums it up yeah
great stuff